so at the beginning of the school year a
grocery store was built
in the school's old art room but this
isn't your typical grocery store
they don't accept money you pay
with good deeds
anthony love the principal of linda tut
high school joins us now i'm very
excited to meet him welcome anthony
i'm really really honored to meet you
well it's definitely an honor to meet
you oh thank you oh
look at your beautiful store okay
so your story went uber viral
everybody's talking about it tons of
press breaks
which is just so good to know
uh that the good news is in the new
cycle
how did that kind of feel
knowing what you've built and seeing
everybody talking about it well it's
definitely exciting
uh you know when we started the grocery
store i
i didn't expect it to to go nationwide
or even around the world
so it's exciting for us at the school
and it's exciting for the students
that work in the store and you know as
well as the students that shop in the
grocery store
so how did the light bulb of an idea
come
to you so there's been a need identified
in our community and
through a three hundred thousand dollar
grant uh through texas health resources
and the sanger community has uh has
partnered with us
and albertsons we have been able to
address
in food insecurities with our our
students
here at our school and we even reach out
to our community
on tuesday evenings so you have your
students
pay with good deeds what's your advice
on what good deeds are that could be
going above and beyond in the classroom
uh that could be being a positive mentor
or just a friend to another student
who's having a hard time
with something going on at home
and then our students can also earn
extra points
both the bonus points with a job on
campus
they could be an office aide they could
help with the pe classroom or a mentor
in our elementary classroom
so it's it's really exciting i heard
a little story about a girl who
had lunch some other person didn't she
offered up hers
she got points for that absolutely
yes it was a third grade student that we
had there was a mix up with our lunches
and one of our students didn't have a
lunch and so
she uh you know through the kindness of
her heart that she reached out
and and she offered her lunch to the
other student
and she waited until we were able to to
get another lunch
so that was really special we she
received a positive
office referral we contacted her parents
let her parents know how awesome that
she was uh and so she was rewarded with
bonus points that she could
shop in the grocery store and get some
food or supplies for
her family to take home i feel like
what you're doing is not only so
invaluable for
the well-being of all these people but
it is teaching a course
and something that i feel not only
might be lacking in schools but that
every school
could benefit from yes absolutely the
you know the ceiling is you know there
there is no limit
for the possibilities or ways that
schools can
have a program like this and just the
students that can be evolved
so i've been contacted from schools
around
the united states from canada uh
from you know the united kingdom so it's
it's definitely out there and i've sat
and talked on the phone
uh with everyone that contacts me so i
i i'm excited about where this place you
know with this program can go
and the impact that it can have uh in
our community
well we um here at this show
would just love to get involved i'm so
personally inspired
by what you are doing i do see endless
possibilities for your program because
it's really two-fold it's helping
families
be nourished and get the food they need
and it's teaching behaviors
that are so vital so necessary
and so wonderful it's these are the
things that make the world a better
place so
our friends at calafia farms a brand i'm
very passionate about heard your story
and
they want to donate ten thousand dollars
towards your grocery store
i i i'm so honored to be speaking to you
and
i'm not gonna lie i am really
moved by what you are doing um and
i'd like to add another ten thousand
dollars to that
i also want to kind of
check back in and see if there's more to
do here i'm percolating i have a ton of
ideas
this is really your program but i'd like
to explore
any possibilities that we might have in
our arsenal
because i know this is something that
you want to get into other schools
absolutely uh you know i've talked with
the uh
some people from texas health resources
and they they want to expand this
program
throughout at least throughout texas
and so you know that's exciting just to
be the
the model that everybody looks at and
based their program off of us so that's
really exciting
i just thank you for bringing this out
into the world
as an example and a format of something
that can really work
and um like i said i'd love to be in
touch because i'm
i'm in awe of you i cannot thank you
guys enough thank you
the pleasure is all ours anthony love
thank you so much thank you
thank you thank you
you